Film Courage: What is the most amount of time
you’ve put into a screenplay and was it
worth it?
David Wappel, Screenwriter: The most amount
of time I’ve put into a screenplay?
It’s tough because I haven’t measured
exactly how much time I’ve worked on it
but I know that the longest from an idea to
a finished draft was five years and that’s
just to the end of the screenplay.
That’s just it still sitting there.
No film has been made.
That is five years what is to me a finished
draft sort of working on it sporadically sometimes
every day.
Other times it kind of sat dormant for a few
months and I worked on other projects or whatever
but that’s the longest of anything I’ve
ever done (five years).
Film Courage: Why did it take so long?
Maybe that’s not a long time?
David: I think it took awhile and it was written
in sort of fits and starts because it was
one of the first projects I started once I
started seriously writing so I didn’t know
yet…not necessarily that I didn’t know
what I was doing because at times I still
don’t feel like know what I I’m doing
when I write a screenplay but I didn’t know
a process that worked for me in terms of creating
something.
So I just started writing.
I had a loose outline and I just started writing
and I kept hitting dead end after dead end
or I would figure something out that didn’t
feel like a dead end but it wasn’t interesting
to me.
It’s just wasn’t…nothing was happening.
So I essentially had to continuously start
it over and over because I didn’t have a
process yet that I felt conformable with and
I didn’t really know what I was interested
in writing about.
I had a story idea but I didn’t know why
that was a story idea that interested me.
Moving forward it was always important to
me that when I was writing something that
I always understood that before I really got
into it why I am interested in that story
and why I am going to take that across the
finish line.
That has been a really useful tool to help
with other story ideas that I’ve had that
I think would be g great movies.
I think they are so cool but I am maybe not
the one to write that so I shouldn’t go
after that yet.
But there is still something that might interest
me so I’ll keep it in there and at some
point I go Oh, that’s what I’m interested
in.
That’s the theme that comes out of that
story that resonates with me and now I am
ready to start digging into that.
Film Courage: It sounds like that story has
a lot of meaning for you (the initial idea)?
David: Now it does.
It didn’t at first because I didn’t have
anything but once I discovered that I was
able to finish it and bring it across the
finish line and understand that I was interested
in writing about.
Film Courage: Do you think you will have this
made at some point or is it almost like…you
know how some people say this isn’t the
story for me to make but it’s a great idea?
David: I think at this point it’s a story
that I would love to see made but in terms
of where I am in my career right now it’s
a very big project.
This was at a time when I was writing before
considerations of my career.
What is the best story that I can write and
get into the hands of producers I know and
have relationships with.
So this project just isn’t a good fit for
the people I know right now so it’s still
just kind of sitting dormant.
It’s been out to a few people to read for
feedback and thoughts but nothing has really
happened with it yet.
Question For The Viewers: What is the most
amount of time you have put into writing a
screenplay and was it worth it?